grosse nouvelle qui retient l'attention
ce matin et c'est pas terminé la journée
jeunes avant d'en reparler toute la
journée Québec dépose son projet de loi
pour élargir l'aide médicale à mourir le
nombre de Québécois qui ont eu recours à
cette procédure est passée 2000 à plus
de 5000 en 5 ans c'est une hausse
finalement qui place le Québec au
premier rang mondial nous allons en
parler avec le docteur Georges
l'espérance président de l'Association
québécoise pour l'aide médicale à mourir
dans la dignité bonjour Docteur
bon alors
vous vous êtes un praticien de la
médicale à mourir vous envoyez vous en
consultez de ces gens-là
qu'est-ce qui explique
que les gens se tournent à tel point
vers cette procédure de fin de vie
[Musique]
une vis et je peux dire moi je ne vois
pas du tout de contradiction d'aucune
façon il faut dire aussi un autre
élément particulier c'est que comme vous
le savez très bien le Québec a mis
beaucoup la religion de côté et donc je
pense que ça aussi joue les gens sont
plus orientés vers disons leur
philosophie de vie sur leur propre
perception de leur évolution et donc ils
ne veulent pas vivre les derniers mois
ou années de leur vie dans des
conditions qu'il trouve pour indigne on
fait beaucoup d'analyses sur la qualité
des services à tous les niveaux dans le
milieu de la santé est-ce que la qualité
des soins palliatifs pourrait être en
cause est-ce que des gens qui disent oh
moi je finirai pas comme ceci ou comme
cela parce qu'on a vu des images durant
la pandémie
c'est pas c'est pas la seule solution la
médicale à mourir les soins mais les
soins palliatifs sont-ils sont-ils de
bons niveaux de niveau acceptable est-ce
qu'on peut en faire plus
les soins palliatifs de fin de vie sont
très bien faits les gens selon les
derniers chiffres des dernières années
les 80% des personnes qui ont eu des qui
ont eu l'aide médicale à mourir avaient
d'abord eu des soins palliatifs ou les
gens refusé pour des raisons qui leur
appartiennent c'est pas tout le monde
qui veut aller jusqu'au bout de sa
souffrance malgré la qualité des soins
palliatifs c'est un faux débat de faire
un rapport un parallèle entre le manque
de soins palliatifs et le recours à
l'aide médicale à mourir l'aide médicale
à mourir c'est un outil de plus dans les
soins palliatifs ou dans les soins de
fin de vie surtout mais ça n'ayez pas de
rapport vous avez beau donner les
meilleurs soins palliatifs au monde la
personne qui par exemple sauf de
sclérose latérale amiotrophique mais
elle veut pas se voir détériorer elle
veut pas savoir avec un respirateur et
multiplier les exemples autant que vous
voulez c'est une question de choix
personnel c'est vrai tant pour les gens
qui ont des cancers que pour des gens
qui une maladie neurodégénératives
cognitives ou des maladies neurologiques
dégénératives telles sclérose en plaques
non c'est vraiment une question de choix
personnel de qualité de vie de la peur
alors si je vous comprends bien on a pas
s'inquiéter il y a pas un dérapage de
tout à coup les gens disent ah ça se
peut pas on peut pas me donner le
service moi j'en peux plus ce que vous
dites non c'est qui il y a des services
mais c'est vraiment l'étape après les
soins palliatifs
je peux vous dire que dans ma pratique à
moi ce n'est jamais arrivé pas une seule
fois sur quelques centaines de patients
au moins une centaine de patients mais
collègues je n'ai jamais entendu ça non
plus de leur part que un patient demande
l'aide médicale amoureux parce qu'il n'a
pas les services de réadaptation ou de
ou de soins palliatifs ou tout ce que
tout comme les services ce n'est pas
vrai les gens veulent vivre mais ils
arrivent un moment donné où ils se
disent ben vivre dans cette condition là
moi je n'en veux plus parce que vous
disiez c'est réconfortant quelque part
parce que faudrait pas qu'on qu'on
dérape du côté là parce que il y a pas
d'autres solutions pour se faire soigner
alors vous nous rassurez docteur
espérance merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
à la prochaine
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]